is this about your recent anal fissure
Jesus yes
I'm Alexis is Jesus a member of your
family plan okay I think we've heard
enough
okay who designed this offensive pseudo
person and Unleashed it on my customers
we did you and I excuse me is team
leader here at Oracle it's my job to
interpret the date okay you know if I
want to hear a new voice in one week
what
good afternoon mr. Larsen how was your
meeting it was a disaster hmm
close your eyes breeze with me because
whatever happens we will deal with it
together
Sansa helped okay Emily should be the
voice well when guests walk into the
hotel I usually say welcome back welcome
back thanks for choosing well tricks I
go forward with Emily that's great we're
gonna move I think it disconnected I
think we make a good team about 30,000
she sounds exactly like you obviously
it's more predictable we are all
predictable well I'm not actually you
are I have the data that I enjoy
listening to you
can you just leave it Jo Larson I'm with
you repeat Jo I'm with you she is
patient and smart she makes my life
better every day and I know she will do
the same for you I am done trying to
pretend I am perfect whatever it is we
will deal with it together we made her
and she helps people
either you're using your life or you
work you're not using your life in your
work you need to get some help man I'm
Kayla if you're busy doing I can't
really Joe I'm
I'm with you I'm
are you still with me
you